[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know
this is our
get together where we get to study the
word of god we get to answer your
questions and we make you this promise
if an answer can be found in the word
from the word we will find that answer
and give it to you
we are convinced and convicted that you
don't need to hear
man's mindset during this particular
program you need to hear a word from the
lord from the word of god and that is
what we promise to always give you if
there is a word from the lord that can
be found we will indeed find it and give
it to you from god's holy word we make
you that promise i am in the company of
a person that i've come to know and love
and like uh as a fellow brother in the
word and as a fellow laborer in the
cause this is pastor daniel gover senior
pastor of the fresno central seventh-day
adventist church pastor good to have you
here nice to be here yeah in pastor
boris absence he is on the road as it
were traveling even now
to i believe it's in michigan no he's
going to uh
he's going to
[Music]
new bedford massachusetts
then i know he's going to to michigan
but he's going to new bedford
massachusetts going to do some meetings
there so he had to get started today and
he asked pastor gover knowing him to be
a student of the word and a preacher of
the word so we felt very very safe in
asking the pastor to uh to come and be
with us and to take the other chair and
thank you pastor again for for being
here thank you if you would have prayer
for us we'll start out uh before we do
that though let me let me say this if
you would like to participate because we
want to give you an opportunity to send
in your questions we have a rather
impressive list of questions so we're
not lacking for questions but we always
want to entertain more
tv at some tv.org
is the address tv at some tv s-u-m-t-v
dot o-r-g send in your questions and
again we will do our best to answer
those questions now my dear pastor
different would you let us pray
our father in heaven thank you so much
for this opportunity to study our word
together
thank you for the questions that we are
receiving here at secrets unsealed and
thank you for your word that is so clear
and powerful amen i pray that your holy
spirit may guide our tongues our minds
and our hearts and the hearts of all of
those who are watching i pray in the
name of jesus amen
amen and amen
our first item is not really a question
per se it's an announcement that um was
sent to pastor boer
this concerns a series of meetings
that will be held in chile
on espiritual television
broadcasting in the valparaiso region of
chile from 10 pm
beginning saturday
september 11th until
uh saturday september 18. so they're
going on right now the campaign was
called firm until the end these are a
rebroadcast of messages preached by
pastor bohr in spanish and we wanted to
give
dare we say a shout out to those who are
watching from chile because we know we
have an audience there that these
meetings are going on you want to attend
them
there it's called firm until the end and
uh pastor bohr is the speaker so you
want to take advantage of that
opportunity and we are so very happy for
that they're in the valparaiso region of
chile now we go to our questions pastor
um
we'll take a look at this one um
dealing with the word jehovah or the
name jehovah which sort of launched into
that the question coming from lynette
asks
why do you not name the true
god by name which is jehovah or yahweh
as there are many gods in this world is
your god one or many
oh thank you annette for this question
very interesting question now
it is true that
jehovah or yahweh is the name of the
true god according to the bible however
the way you and i pronounce it i'm
trying to say it with an american accent
although i'm portuguese
it's really not the way that jewish
people would pronounce it actually
jewish orthodox jews would not even
pronounce
this name let's call it the name or
adonai the lord
because it's such a holy name for the
orthodox jew
and even you know as we we may say
jehovah yahweh there's nothing wrong
with that
but there's no real evidence or there's
no assurance in theology and the study
of the bible in the study of scripture
there's no assurance that we have the
right vowels there's really not i mean
there are so many videos and studies you
can watch out there
but
theologians who are very serious like i
just read um
a little post by
one of the translators of the new
american standard bible you know there's
an update in 2020
and
um he was saying and he this is a man
that really knows
hebrew and all of this and he was saying
we don't have nobody is a hundred
percent sure that yahweh is the right
pronunciation so jehovah may be the
right pronunciation it may not yahweh
may be the right pronunciation may not
so
when you are saying the name of god
yahweh or jehovah
you are saying something that the jews
would not pronounce and we know the
consonants what what they are but we do
not know the vowels
so
i think
what god really wanted is to give to
moses when he revealed to him as the i
am in exodus chapter 3 to give to moses
another glimpse into his character
the name of god name in the bible is not
just what you pronounce but it has to do
with the character of the individual so
god is depicted with many different
names i have a few here we can call him
god almighty el shaddai we can call him
the lord will provide right that's what
abraham called him in genesis 22 the god
of abraham isaac and jacob he actually
called himself the god of abraham isaac
and nate and jacob
um the god of israel the lord of hosts a
consuming fire god is a consuming fire
so all these things point to the
character of god more than just a
correct pronunciation because
as you know
we in the united states we read the
bible in one language with one sound
in portugal we read the bible with
another sound another language you may
be saying the same name but with a
different accent so the correct
pronunciation of a word concerning god
i don't think that's the most important
thing but who he is if we are worshiping
the true god
we are worshiping the god that is
revealed in scripture he has revealed
himself with many names to give us a
better idea and a better glimpse of who
he is as a person who what his character
is so
i think that even though you can say
jehovah yahweh if you prefer
i don't think we have to
mention that specific word to be
addressing the right god and i think we
have good bible evidence for what i'm
saying in matthew chapter six when jesus
says when you pray
you just say our father father our
father who is in heaven so jesus called
him the holy father as well in genesis
in
john 17. so
i think that like ellen white said
when we call him father that is music to
his ears amen amen amen well said just
to add a couple other things to what a
pastor has so eloquently said
jehovah of course the name in the old
testament was never spoken so uh as he
he said rightly um you you cannot know
because it was not spoken it was it was
considered too sacred to speak so where
did we get jehovah from now jehovah is
not an original manuscript bible word
when they were translating they needed
to
lock onto something that was
speakable that was mentionable so what
they did
they took yahweh
the the closest transliteration is j
h
uh v h
the vowels come from the word adonai
they took the word adonai that a
d is is a the consonant another o
n a so they put the a
the o and the a
into yahweh or jehovah and that's how
they came up with jehovah so they had
something they could speak
and they could say so jehovah is not
original because the original was never
spoken so
you can't say it is the name for god
because it's a i want to say a made-up
name but it is it's an invented name
that was uh done uh during the times of
the
translation of the septuagint the
seventy because they needed to have
something that they could speak and they
could work with
um i like your point that
in the old testament in particular god
was identified by how he dealt with his
people so you had el shaddai you had el
elyon you had el olam in the very first
text of the bible
elohim
in the beginning god created the heaven
and earth the earth and of course the
elohim is a plural ending the i am is a
plural ending so uh it's a it's a very
nuanced system
the people saw god
in terms of god's dealing with his
people the god gracious the god-kind the
god and merciful the god of supplies the
god who keeps his covenants the god was
all-powerful each one of these was a
different name given to god
in response to his dealing with his
people so jehovah is just one
rather limited expression of who god is
because god is vast yes you know uh the
shema hear o israel the lord your god
the lord is one one yes but there's
plural language till you get to the end
and it's one so there's much to know
about god
really
using only jehovah limits who god is yes
because god has so many things to so
many people what's important is that
he's there when you need him he's right
when you need him as you need him and he
is a god calling him father pleases him
if it pleases him pleases me amen amen
now i like the way the the french people
have translated
this name and in many of our bible
translations instead of instead of
yahweh you have lord
and in french many good translations
have le ternel meaning the eternal one
which actually the name yahweh if you
want to call it that way seems to point
to this eternal presence yes so again
god is
shrouded in mystery
and he reveals himself to us that's why
we know him because he has revealed
himself to us and he has revealed
himself in so many different ways and
with so many different names and each of
these names gives us a glimpse into who
he is and he is the eternal self-present
he is the one who is the i am he lives
because of the life that is in himself
and so the name yahweh or jehovah seems
to point to that reality so what it
means
is way more important than the way it
sounds
amen amen my two cents we could throw in
another little wrinkle another spoonful
of sugar in that um we are told in
spirit of prophecy that the dealings
between
god and man
was the pre-incarnate christ so the i am
that i am who introduced himself as to
moses that way yes was jesus amen was
was that personage so um you know
usually we see capital l capital o
capital r capital d uh that translation
so it's it's it's a good area of study
pastor it is and uh uh we can learn much
but we don't want to just limit him to a
word that was invented so that he was a
little easier to pronounce but there are
many many many uh
expressions of god and is dealing with
mankind yes and and an interesting thing
also is to
uh remember that it is
is not by us pronouncing
one word correctly that we are all of a
sudden protected by the true god
that could not be so that would be
superstition right
um if we are praying to the true god our
father the the one who created the
heavens and the earth who gave his son
to die for us if we are praying to the
god of the bible he is not picky he
knows that we are limited human beings
fallible and sometimes we fumble through
words a little bit
and it's not because we pronounce it
correctly
like i my name is daniel govaya and it
is i've come to notice that it is very
hard for an american speaker to say my
last name go by it
however
because people sometimes mispronounce my
name that doesn't change me doesn't
change who i am and that doesn't change
my love towards those people because i
know they were brought up in a country
where govaya is not a very common name
yeah so you know
so they're talking to me and that's the
most important thing that's the most
important thing you know that brings
something to my mind whenever i listen
to you my mind begins to race yeah you
you you serve as a muse for my thinking
when i was in new york i had a talk show
uh christian ordinances talk called this
moment in time uh
people often ask what's the ca well it's
clement augustus
so i would say on the radio this is
clement murray and i would get no call
the phone would just sit there and so i
asked my producer what's wrong she said
i think it's that clement
she said it's first of all it's
difficult for americans they don't like
names where you've got to take the word
from the back your mouth to the front of
the mouth clement is not going to work
what's your middle name i said augustus
she said oh no
that's not going to fly either so she
said what can we do okay ca see it
that's right that's where ca came from
it's quick it's kind of radio you can
say this is ca murphy's a good ranking
and the call is beginning to come in you
know so she was right she's like clement
augustus no too much work daniel govaia
yeah a lot of work you know and
americans don't like to work so hard
it's hard so the name is not important
it's the fact that you're addressing god
if you say lord i don't know who you are
i've never talked to you before but i
need your help i want to surrender
myself to you he'll hear it
and he's promised to do this amen good
question very good question thank you
thank you all right the second question
deals with
um hello blessings to you all my bible
question is this
in today's day and age
can we be translated to heaven or even
be resurrected before jesus comes just
like enoch
elijah and moses now i saw a little
opening there
because the question as asked is can we
can we yeah well yes we can
yeah the question is will we or is there
any
evidence for that so the question has
asked can we
god can do what he pleases oh yes uh he
he he can do that do all things now is
there any biblical evidence for us to
think that that's gonna happen that's
where i think the question lies yeah i
don't i don't think there's biblical
evidence to say that that's going to
happen to any one of us even though like
pastor c is saying definitely can i mean
god can do everything you know he can
just
snap his fingers and all of a sudden
poof take us to heaven however
would that be good for us are we ready
is our character ready and
would that be something that we should
desire we would say yes because we all
want to be with jesus in heaven forever
amen if we're true followers of the lamb
however however
there's a lot of suffering in the world
right there is a good a big mission to
for every follower of jesus today on
this earth
so we should really temper that desire
with the desire to be as jesus was and
to serve suffering humanity
now there's an interesting text in
thessalonians first thessalonians 4 that
i always like to quote when we think
about
this of us going to heaven and i'm going
to point it out
because of a specific reason
so it says first thessalonians 4 the
whole passage from verse 13 to 18 is
very important but
i like to quote
this from verse 15 says for this we say
to you by the word of the lord that we
who are alive and remain until the
coming of the lord
will by no means precede those who are
asleep
for the lord himself will descend from
heaven with a shout
with the voice of an archangel and with
the trumpet of god and the dead in
christ will rise first
then we who are alive and remain
shall be caught up together this word
together is very important yes together
with them in the clouds to meet the lord
in the air and thus we shall always be
with the lord now
i think our culture is infected with
this virus
of individualism and that you know we
see hollywood movies and we think that
uh in in reality and in in the bible
religion and in in what god does for
human beings it's almost the same thing
we look at
enoch elijah moses and other bible
characters and we think these are the
true heroes of faith i want i want to be
like one of them
i think that god had a very special
purpose for enoch when god took him to
heaven there was a corrupted generation
it was a pre-dilivine world
god was about to destroy everything and
everybody except for noah and his family
and god wanted to show
through the example of enoch that
serving god and walking with god is the
best thing you can do there's a
difference between the righteous and the
unrighteous yeah you look at elijah same
thing the people of israel were
corrupted yes there were seven thousand
that had had not kissed baal
but nevertheless he was the only one
that stood firm for god and mount carmel
against 450 prophets and
all the people who did not know what
they were doing so there was a great
spiritual crisis in israel and god
wanted to show that if you walk with god
you give yourself entirely to god god
has a wonderful plan for you
that is beyond this world same thing
with moses his resurrection was very
special it talks to you about people who
will die after a life of sacrifice for
god they do not see the fulfillment of
their dreams in this life
moses was not
allowed to enter the promised land
but as soon as he
he died
god raised him from the dead and he was
taken to heaven so he will have the
fulfillment of all these dreams and much
more in heaven
so i believe that god has a special
purpose for each and every one of us
it doesn't mean that if when we read
these stories we cannot we should um
take for ourselves the lessons that are
trying to convey to us we should walk
with god like enoch walked we should be
faithful like elijah was faithful we
should trust god like moses trusted even
if we don't see the fulfillment of our
dreams
and we should not try
to
to just go ahead of everybody because
there's a beauty here in going together
right amen because if i walk with god to
such an extent that
my character is perfect and i am ready
to be translated into heaven
and i go and i leave my wife and my
young son here down below on earth
that's not fair you know they will
suffer without me yeah
enoch was 300 years old his son was 300
no enoch was
365 years old his son was already 300
years old his first son for what we know
so he went when everything was ready and
for a special purpose
we need to be careful not to try to be
you know
the one that really gets it
god can do it yes i think god is even
more this he's desiring
he's anxious to finish this separation
more than we are
um but he has a purpose for us here he
has a plan for you and for me and we
should be faithful until the end
faithful until death and he will give us
the crown of life well said um this is
from juan i think
a couple of things popping in mind
something you alluded to moses was an
example of those who
live in the lord died in the lord and
were resurrected taken heaven elijah
will be
was a representative of those who
will be translated and not see death but
here's the thing
uh to think about and and we're going to
run out of time uh but i'll try to get
through this point moses and elijah came
down to comfort christ in the garden of
gethsemane yes can you imagine what that
conversation was like you remember they
were in on a promissory note christ had
not died yet christ's sacrifice was not
realized yet so they were in
on the
prayer the wish the hope that christ
would be successful if christ had failed
they would have had to come back because
they would have no redeemer so can you
imagine that conversation you know jesus
please you can't fail because if you
fail we got to come back we can't stay
so it was a powerful conversation isn't
that amazing that
human beings that are raised
from the one is raised from the dead
another is translated into heaven
they were already in heaven for many
years enjoying the wonders of the direct
presence of god and they come down to
talk to jesus
at the mount of transfiguration and the
gospel of blue tells us they are talking
about the cross yes because for each and
every human being
the most important thing
in the history of the universe is that
you will live eternally
because jesus suffered
the the weight and the pain of eternal
death for you on that cross yes yes so
this is what really draws us so close to
god the sacrifice of christ and we
embracing that cross in our lives daily
and whatever god wants for us if it is
to fly okay we'll fly but
many times god wants us to really suffer
and and bleed and and sweat for the
salvation of others and that's walking
very close to jesus as well indeed i
think i might have said gardening
seminar i meant mount of transfiguration
but suffice it to say they came to
encourage him ellen white spent just a
little time in heaven envisioned and she
said i didn't want to come back yeah you
know i just i was just there for a
little while they had been there for
quite some time so if you spend one
moment in heaven you don't want to come
back down here she said it's dark and
it's lonely
so surely they were encouraging christ
you can make it you have to make it all
of heaven is pulling for you because if
you don't make it not only will
humanity be lost we've got to come back
and we don't want to come back but we
praise the lord praise the lord for that
and and we remember the words of jesus
that he said that
the will of the father that sent him is
that anyone that sees him and believes
in him
uh will be saved then he will resurrect
him in the last day that's john chapter
6 verse 40 and many other verses and
this is the will of him who sent me that
everyone who sees the son and believes
in him may have everlasting life
and i will raise him up at the last day
that is the promise that you and i have
that we will be raised at the last day
yeah if for any cosmic reason god sees
fit that he will raise us from the dead
before that well he can do that right
but uh we are not given that promise in
the bible yeah there is something
really neat
about all of us going together yes you
know the dead in christ shall rise first
which is just an order
then we then we enter our live and
remain so we'll all be caught up we'll
all be going together that that's just
the visual to that is so strong and so
powerful that we'll all be caught up i
was studying the bible with a lady once
and she was so shocked to find out that
the dead people are dead and sleeping in
the sleep of the first death and she was
like oh this is so hard for me
um you know i'm of age and i've always
thought that my family went up ahead and
they're just throwing a party
so i took her to this passage and i said
you know what god is so good and he
doesn't want them to have a party
without us yes
he wants us to go all together and we'll
throw the party together we'll throw the
party and that seems you know that seems
great you know if if if if they were in
heaven
and were aware and cognizant of what's
going down on here on earth here now
pastor there could be no party yeah not
exactly 600 and something thousand dead
with covid not with the earthquakes the
tornadoes the the murder the
the carnage
that does not induce party spirit to me
heaven would be a pretty dreary place
looking at what is going on here and now
so when we go we all go together sin
will be no more the bible says if there
are no tears christ will wipe away those
tears amen that will be a true party
amen we can praise the lord we can
praise the lord for them
all right we are down you know time goes
so fast we've gotten through two whole
questions
yeah and try to do our best the next
question i don't think we're gonna have
time to deal with because it deals with
romans chapter seven verses one through
six there's a lot in there
and then there's another question about
uh creation again these are questions
that are going to chew up a little bit
of our time and we don't want to short
shift anyone as far as their questions
are concerned okay so we're going to
encourage you uh to write in your
questions we will take the best and and
you see we try not to rush through your
questions
there are questions that are some are
light questions some are very heavy some
are very very deep and some need to be
wrestled with a little bit more than
others so we try to take sufficient time
to deal with your questions uh i am glad
to have the pastor with me here uh good
head good thinker good student of the
world so we appreciate you pastor and i
can offer the invitation because i'm an
associate speaker anytime pastor boer is
away we'll bring you on in here i'm sure
he would not
all right and of course you've worked
with him so far so if i'm away you can
take my you can take my chair off all
right we praise the lord for that thank
you again
tv at some tv.org
tv some tv.org we will do our best to
answer your questions we will do our
best to bring them to you from the word
and give you scripture chapter and verse
as i say for them all because in these
last days what you need to hear is the
word of god what you need to understand
is the word of god not the mind of man
but the word of the lord until we see
again our time is fast slipped into
eternity may god bless you as together
we worship him in spirit and in truth
[Music]
you